so I think I'll still spend like five
minutes just briefly review
um on the the bad propagation last time
I think I I was running behind last time
so so I didn't have time to explain this
figure which I think probably would be
useful as a high level summary of what's
Happening uh I'm going to Omit all the
details so so I guess I'm drawing this
in this way like this is the forward
path this is how you define a network
and the loss function right so you start
with some example X and then you have
some
I guess this is a matrix back to
multiplication or Matrix Matrix
modification if you have multiple
examples but this is a matrix Vector
message multiplication module and you
take this you take X in a product of
multiply with w and B and then you get
some activation the pre-activation and
you get some post activation you take
some Matrix Vector multiplication and
you get
um I guess I'm using I'm matrix
multiplication but actually it's Matrix
Factor multiplication so uh and you get
the activation and then you do this
right this is the how you define the
loss how you define the model I guess
the output of the model I think last
time we used tall which is the output of
the model and then you have something
that defines that defines the logs right
this is the the so-called forward path
and
and and the in some sense the the you
can summarize the the back propagation
uh in a way uh like follows so basically
if I draw it right so this is uh of
course you know what you really do is
you implement this in computer
um but if you draw it in some sense you
are doing it in a backward way so what
you do is you say you first compute
if you look at the the flow the data
flow or the kind of the com the process
of the back props um back prop process
so you compute uh the laws with respect
to uh the output first and this is often
very easy this is like just you take the
because the loss is something like y
minus Tau Square Times a half and this
one is just a very simple formula and
then you compute
um
you can you compute
the derivative of the loss with respect
to a two here I only have three layers
so and then you take the derivative you
compute the derivative of loss with
respect to
Z2 and then you compute the derivative
of loss with respect to uh A1
and then something like this this is the
the order of the computation
uh you walked and and this is kind of
like it's kind of like you are actually
in this networking in a backward fashion
in some sense
um but how do you do this each of this
Arrow so this is by the the Lemma that
we discussed right so so I think we have
three landmarks or three abstractions
right so and each of this arrow is using
one of those three elements so and and
now you can see what this those kind of
like landmarks are for those dilemmas
basically are saying that if you know
DJ over dtau how do you compute d0 over
d a and and there's another element
which says that if you know how to
compute DJ over da how do you compute DJ
over DZ and and all of those slime us
about this kind of relationship if you
know how to compute
um the derivative with respect to the
output of some module right suppose this
is a module towards the output of this
module right so if you know how to
compute DJ over D the output of the
module then you want to know how to
compute the derivative with with respect
to input of the module so all of the
three lemas are doing these things I'm
not going to the details because you
know we don't have enough time to review
again but that's the basic idea and
um and also there's another thing which
is like this is only about the
derivative with respect to activation
you can also compute a derivative with
respect to the the weights right so if
you know this quantity then uh I think
if you know this quantity then you know
how to compute the derivative with back
to the last layer weight
and if you know
this quantity
then you know from this quantity you
know how to compute
the derivative with back to W2
and from this quality you know how to
compute derivative with respect to W1
and also the same thing for for Beats
so
um and and this kind of the the last row
this quantities right so they are they
don't depend on for example after you
get this you can compute this right and
after you get this quantity you can
complete these two quantities but this
this Row the derivative with respect to
activations you can only do it
sequentially you cannot say you compute
this before you do this so so this
arrows kind of is kind of the the orders
of the dependencies between these
quantities
and um and and each of these Arrow you
know is basically done by one of the
Lima that we discussed last time right
each of the Lima is kind of dealing with
the
um with this
any questions
this is just the extension of the last
five minutes of the option I didn't have
enough time to elaborate on this
okay so
um good so now in this lecture and the
lecture afterwards we are talking about
um
um I guess a few Concepts one concept is
called generalization
which is the main point of this lecture
and also next lecture we're going to
talk about on the concept of
regularization
and next action we also talk about some
of the practical
a Viewpoint of ml like how do you really
tune your model how do you uh whatever
you have to do in this whole process
right so like you start with the data
process and then you have to tune a
model and then maybe you have to go back
to change your data so on and so forth
so
um so basically these two lectures I
think we are
um
um we're gonna discuss this kind of
um this concept I think the
generalization is probably the main
thing that we are talking about here so
um so generalization as you can see you
know as you can guess it's really just
about you know how well you are your
model is performing on Einstein test
examples
so we're going to discuss you know how
do you make sure your model can also
generalize to unseen test examples so so
far we only talk about training right so
we have some examples which we have seen
when they are tuning data sets and we
fetch some model on top on them right so
and now we care about whether this model
will work for future unseen examples
so and we are going to discuss you know
um on a bunch of Concepts you know the
bearings very straight off which is
which is a kind of a principle when you
think about how test error changes as
you change model complexity and we're
going to talk about some of the new
phenomena people have found in deep
learning which is a little bit different
from the classical understanding
um okay so I guess uh um that's just a
very high level overview I guess I use a
lot of passwords I'm not expecting
everyone to follow everything so um let
me um maybe be concrete
um okay so I guess so let me start with
some kind of basic notations and Notions
so I guess some basic Notions one thing
is this so-called tuning
loss which you probably already know
what it means you know shooting laws or
sometimes it's called tuning error
sometimes it's called training cost I
think in in this lecture sometimes we
use the word cost so they all mean uh
the similar type of Concepts sometimes
people use loss to refer certain kind of
losses and error to refuse refers to
certain other type of losses but but
they are from the purpose of this
lecture they are all means same thing
right this is what you care about in a
tuning right for example if you care
about the square loss then the training
loss will just be this
I think we have to write down we have
written down this equation of times this
is the loss function you care about when
you have square loss
and other laws could be cross entropy
laws it could be
um um like a mle the maximum likelihood
estimator I think that's actually one
principle to derive the tuning loss
right you derive the maximum likelihood
estimator for uh for a data set and that
you use that as your training loss you
use the negative log likelihood as the
tuning loss so this is basically so far
what we have focused on in the last few
weeks so how do you get the feeling loss
and how do you really Implement on this
and optimize this right so there are
many ways to optimize it for example in
one of the lectures we use the
analytical formulas right so we we have
the GDA we analytically compute what is
the the minimum loss right the minimum
uh uh the minimizer of the negative log
likelihood and it's you know of the
other lectures we are using a numerical
algorithm to minimize this loss right so
like we for example like in deep
learning we are using stochastic wind
descent
um and we have talked about Newton's
methods so and so forth but so far
everything we have to talk about is this
loss function when we try to find the
minimizer of the source function
or some oh you know not necessarily
exactly this one but like either the but
always it's always a loss function
defined on the training examples
okay so now
um suppose you have obtained right so
suppose we have some parameters Theta so
suppose we have obtained
um some SATA
how do you evaluate what you're saying
is good or not so ideally you want to
model to not only perform well on the
tuning data because for the tuning data
you already know the prediction right
why you care about letting the model to
predict something you already know you
already know so what you really care
about is you care about you know you
want to evaluate
on unseen examples
so that's why the test loss is defined
um and I'm going to use this notion
so suppose let's say you draw
so the process is that you draw some new
example
X comma y from some distribution D and
often this is called test distribution
and and then you evaluate
what's the expected loss on this new
Test example so you look at L Theta
which is the expected loss
of
and the expectation is over the
randomness of this new example
Juan from this test description
so what's important is that this X and Y
is not seen in the training it's a new
Fresh example and of course here I'm
defining it as expectation right so
actually in places I'm taking average
over the entire discussion so so if you
really want to do it in parallel
what this really means is that you draw
a bunch of examples
maybe let's call it X1 test
test one
you draw maybe I'm of this
these are another examples you have used
for training these are new examples you
draw
during the test time you draw them from
B ID from the distribution d
and then you evaluate the Empire the
error on this side so and you evaluate
average error
on average loss
on on this set on the test set
because you know that if you evaluate on
this test set uh it's it's pretty much
just approximating this expectation you
are just using empirical way to estimate
the expected value
right like if you want to if you want to
estimate any expect an expectation of
any random variable one way to do it is
you just draw multiple copies from the
same distribution and you take the
empirical average right that's why the
test set is a reasonable estimate for
the
um for the test error
and just to be clear these test examples
you know you don't you haven't seen them
in a changing site they are something
you draw
um you know you can draw them in advance
but you don't you cannot like them to be
seen in your training uh the tuning
process
and there is a notion called
generalization Gap
foreign
often people called
this is basically talking about the
difference between the test loss and the
tuning loss and oftentimes you know it's
not always true but oftentimes the
training loss is less than a test loss
when you test you found that your model
is not as good as you thought before on
the training set you know you know it's
probably sometimes it's probably a
little bit worse sometimes it's a lot
worse sometimes they are very similar
but generally you shouldn't expect that
your test performance is just
dramatically better than the training
performance I mean of course in extreme
cases you can design data set such that
this happens but but I think in in
realistic practical situations I don't
think you should expect that at all
um so so it's often the case that this
Gap is either very close to zero or
maybe a slightly negative slightly
positive or it's it's much bigger than
zero so you want this Gap to be as small
as possible
so so basically you just in some sense
you care about two points is you care
about
the training loss and you care about the
gap
you want both of these two to be small
if both of these two be small or if both
of them are small then the sum of them
will be small and that's your test by
your test loss is small
um that's that's the hope you hope that
this both of these two are small
foreign
so this one is something you can control
in some sense right this is what you try
to optimize for right but this one is
harder to control because you don't so
right because you cannot say I'm going
to find a data such as L Theta is small
because if you do that in particularly
you try to optimize Theta such that the
Tesla is small then you have to see the
test data set
right so so so so so so that's why you
cannot really easily control this
because you you are not allowed to test
the assets so you like you cannot choose
your Theta based on the loss you can
only choose Theta first and then you
evaluate loss but not vice versa
so that's why the the generalization Gap
is something that is very hard to
control at least you cannot directly
control it you know and and the the
point of this lecture is to discuss you
know in what cases you can somewhat no
this is not too big right like when this
can you can hope that this is not too
big
um
okay so and and then we also did uh
before getting into more details let me
also Define of two notes two kind of
like commonly used uh terminology so
um of course we are dealing with the
case when else so we are mostly
concerned about the case when L say that
it's too big right so if else it is
small that's great right you don't have
to worry about anything so when LCD is
Big the question is what what do we do
to change it right like if You observe
that your test loss is very big then
what you can do to make it smaller
that's the kind of the question you want
to study so and typically when LCD is
Big you can there are two on failure
mode in some sense
these are not supposed to be
um
these are not supposed to be um you know
comprehensive but I think typically you
are in either one of these two failure
modes so one of the filler mode is
called
um
affiliate patterns so one of the failure
mode is called overfitting
and so over 15 you know I'm going to
discuss a lot about overfitting
um but you know the first other bit is
that the typical situation of
overfitting is that the training loss J
is small
but the the test loss is big
so you have this big generalization Gap
so you have a discrepancy between tuning
and test so that's
at least that's you know that's not a
definition for our fitting but that's a
very
um uh a a very typical
um
characteristic of overfitting
so
um for example I guess I'll probably
draw this you know very often uh our job
is going to figure out very often uh in
in this lecture so suppose you have a
um some X and some y you have some data
sets I guess the running example I'm
going to do is that I'm going to have
some
data set that lives very close to this
quadratic quadratic function so the the
data are approximately quadratic so X
and Y so you want to be has a
one-dimensional problem so given X you
want to predict Y and You observe some
um
so you have a data set for example you
have four points so each point is like
this maybe this
and something like this maybe something
like this
right so you have you see these four
blue points and you want to fit a line
to it or filter some curve to it and the
question is what curve you're gonna
affect so suppose you fetch something
crazy like this
let me try to
see what color I'm using for this
well sorry one moment let me
um think about how do I use the color on
your consistent way
so I guess if you fit
I'm going to use black follow for the
model you fit so suppose your model your
fat is something like this
I'm drawing something crazy
so this model
is
I intentionally make this model to pass
these points exactly
so this model face the data the
fortunate data perfectly
right so the J Theta is really small
it's kind of close to zero but you can
imagine this model shouldn't generalize
to anything examples right so suppose
you suppose you
um
regenerate some examples you know and
you kind of believe that ANC examples
also are kind of like similar
um like have a quadratic relationship
you generate something like this maybe
somewhere here maybe somewhere here then
you can see that the The Fading to the
the right Point becomes very worse so
much worse becomes much worse so the so
the test loss is very big so so this is
a typical situation of overfitting in
some sense you are saying that you you
fit to the data very well but you are
you are on you are over fitting in the
sense that you you
um you only focus on the training data
but you you kind of like
um forget about the the test performance
you know I will discuss why this will
happen
um I guess you can probably guess
um but this is for so far I'm just
defining the roughly what over facing
means
so it means that you are not
um you you feel the tuning data but you
don't you don't generalize and another
um uh notion is called underfading
so
an undertaking basically just means that
you face something like this
maybe let's say you fit this
suppose this is another model effect
so underfating just means that both The
The J the J Theta is also big
so so even your model does it doesn't
even do well on a tuning set and that
that is basically means under fitting
um so you as the word suggests that you
are not fitting the data
um
and and whether you're in the
overfitting regime all the underfating
regime or in the in a nicer regime
um depends a lot on different things and
one kind of decision we are trying to
discuss today is that you know what is
the right model complexity
so like whether you're going to use
linear model
maybe use our quadratic
or maybe fifth degree polynomial
or when you might work so and so forth
so we're going to discuss you know uh
what will happen if you change your
model complexity and whether you know in
what cases you may underfade in what
cases you may overfit and what is the
best sweet spot
any questions so far
and
kind of like as a spoiler in some sense
like we're going to discuss two
um we're going to decompose the test
error l Theta
we're going to decompose this into two
terms
actually I'm not going to show it
mathematically because I don't think I
have enough time to do that but
intuitively you're going to decompose
the test error into two terms which is
called one is called bias
and technically it's y squared because
the bias is defined as the square root
of this term
so plus variance
so you're going to have this you're
going to Define these two terms and and
say that these two terms if you take the
sum of them it will be the test error
and these two terms has this property
that's the BIOS
is going to be uh
an increasing function
so we're going to see something like
this the bias is going to be a
decreasing function as the model
complexity
I haven't told you what the bias is what
the virus is I'm just kind of giving
your
kind of like a a spoiler on what kind of
things we are going to discuss so the
bias is something like this
and
a virus is something like this
so these are basically you are kind of
like trying to figure out the underlying
kind of like mechanisms
um so so the mechanism is that if you
change the model complexity to make it
more complex then your bio environments
will be bigger and the bias will be
smaller and your sum of these two
functions which is the test error will
be something like this
and then the best one will be something
in the middle so so this is the kind of
the
uh um a quick overview of what we're
going to discuss
so
all right
okay so now I'm going to
um Define bias and virus
um in a little bit more formal uh ways
still not very formal like like there
there's um like I'm going to start with
uh like it's a great it's a graduate
process I'm gonna have a little more
formal definition of the bias
okay and I saw some uh examples
so any questions so far
why
is crazy I mean oh this is just a maybe
I should draw this is just because it's
kind of a unique thing you need to
define the bias to be the uh it's just
the
um how do I say this like it's a
definition like a like a
actually some people call the the
biosaurus bias actually in some
literature sometimes people take a
square root it's just a how do you
choose the right unit
um
yeah and I I you know when I say bias I
I don't really distinguish whether it's
squared or not it's
so
um okay so I guess um what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to have a running example
which is basically like this and I'm
going to uh kind of like try
um what what happens with linear
50 degree polynomial these are
um and and kind of use this technology
as a solid experiment to demonstrate
these qualities
so
let's start with linear so this is um
sometimes this is a solid experiment but
but actually we have some real data
experiments in the electron notes here
I'm just drawing this
um
um so like
um but I think it's um it's pretty much
the same so so suppose you okay maybe I
will set up just really quick so my
running example is basically like what I
on Drew about
um so so I'm gonna have some training
examples
and these training examples are
something like y i is equals to a
quadratic function
quadratic
which is just this quadratic
um imagine
and plus a little bit noise this is a
small noise
so that's why these blue points are not
exactly like on the quadratic it's just
there is a little bits fluctuation
so
um and sometimes I think
um I guess this quadratic sometimes
they're called as H star XI
just for the sake of technology I think
sometimes I call this the ground shoes
this is the in some sense the the true
function you are trying to find out
um but of course you don't know it you
want to you want to try to recover it
and I'm going to do a cell experiment
first you know I'm going to do a few
experiments I'm going to start with
linear model and then I'm going to try
fifth degree polynomial and then I'm
going to try quadratic
so
um so linear model
suppose you have a linear model
I guess you can probably see you know
what will guys what will happen so I'll
draw this again so you have this
four data points something like this
now what happens with linear model is
that you know you have these four points
what's the best linear effect probably
would be something like
maybe this
for this particular data set
right so
and
and you can see that
uh what's the
what are happening here so
maybe let me see how do I
um maybe let me erase this for the
moment
I'm going to redraw this again
so for linear models I guess you can see
a bunch of properties right so you can
see that this is a large training Arbor
training loss alternate
losses for consistency there's a lot
changing loss because
um I guess
what's your prediction on a tuning data
set this is your prediction for this for
this ax
right so
so this is X1
and the prediction is here and the
prediction Fox 2 is here the prediction
fox 3 is here the prediction for X4 is
here and you look at the distance
between
the production and the true label you
see that the distance is pretty big
right so
um so the channel the Chinese Hardware
is fairly big
and so on and so so this is under 13.
okay by our definition of under 50.
because the tuning is already big
and now let's uh think about so
what what you should blame like why the
training is back what was the what's the
corporate
the the corporate you know I would argue
is that it's just because no only linear
model can fit your data it's not just
right no only linear no any linear model
can can work
and it's not because you don't even have
enough data it's just because you know
like even you have more data
a linear model wouldn't work as well
right so this is just because the linear
model is not expressive enough
so and and that's the and this is called
bias so this is so this is called bias
so we're in this kind of settings
um things happens you like you have
device so the bias is
um
basically like it's saying that okay the
reason why I don't know exactly why
people call It Best in the very first
time but I think you can kind of the the
kind of the relationship the thing is
that you are you are imposing additional
structure right so you are imposing a
linear structure but the true data is
not linear so it doesn't matter how many
data you see if you as long as you
impose this you you just insist that
I just believe that this thing is is
linear you're going to fail because this
is the wrong belief about the
relationship between Y and X
so that's why this is called bias and
this is not you cannot mitigate
cannot be mitigated
by more data as I said
and a nice actually it can also not be
mitigated by less noise even your data
is more and by
less noise data
right because even you have more
data and with less noise
you can imagine what happens right so
suppose you see
a
little bit more data
supposed to see some more data as tuning
data
right and now and maybe let's say you
just no suppose in the extreme case you
just see everything on on this exactly
on this on this quadratic line without
any noise
still if you think about what's the best
fit
for example let's say just you see all
of this blue and the green points and
what's the best effect the best fit
probably would change a little bit
that's true right it probably wouldn't
be exactly this maybe it would be
I guess it would be something like this
maybe
maybe something like this I don't know
like you have to trade off right because
you know whatever you fit right if you
fit this then you you don't fit some of
these examples if you do you know
there's no any option right it's like
whatever it's just because linear model
cannot represent quadratic function
that's it so
so that's the the typical uh situation
where you have a large spice
and mathematically
so the way you define miles so here I'm
just only talking about some
characteristics of having large bars so
mathematically one way to define the
bias you know is that you can say this
is the
um so buyers
is I guess actually there's some
approximation here depending on what
exactly your model is but roughly
speaking is the the
the the best
uh our loss uh you get
you can get
with even infinite data
so you guys I guess you know if you
suppose you have infinite data you have
a data set with infinite data following
the same kind of property right so like
I'll generate from this quadratic plus
noise then what's the best you can do
and that's called Vice
and and you can kind of see that you
know it's probably important for buyers
to be small because if its bias is large
even with infinite data you cannot do
anything right so
um
and that's the that's the problem with
linear models
any questions
the distance
um I think I think that's pretty much
you know uh so for this case they're
pretty much they are the same so
basically
so so in this in this case it's exactly
true that the bias is the best linear
model uh so the closest
like the closest medium or the model
that is closest the the linear model
that is closest to the ground truth and
that error that closeness is is device
right because when you generate infinite
data basically you just generate the
ground truth the whole line right if you
have no noise
you are now changing the model class
you're only using linear but you cannot
okay so buyers would be the best
okay
so in some sense technical reasons to
say bias is is is property of the the
the the family of models right so so the
linear mode the linear model family has
a large price
right I I think you know
um
yeah I think that's that's that you know
we are always talking about model family
right so we're talking about either
linear model family the family of linear
model so the family of fifth degree
polynomial or the family of quadratics
Okay cool so this is the bias and now
let me talk about the virus
um
and here there's you know I'll come back
to the virus for this model but here the
variance is in some sense you can say
it's not very important
only the bias is the corporate and now
I'm going to show cases where the
variance is the corporate to blame for
so
um so I guess I'm gonna really draw
this
so you have
2004 points
okay so now I'm going to fetch a fifth
degree polynomial
so the model is something like hclx is
you know some
Theta 5 x to the 5 plus up to instead of
zero but recall that we can do this with
with linear regression because you just
this is still linear in the Theta right
we have a homework question on this we
also talk about how to do this you know
with kernel methods if if you care about
efficiencies right so so we are able to
do feathers and an intellectual notes
actually there are some visualizations
of the real
the real model is going to fit so here
I'm just gonna draw it so if you fit
your 50 degree polynomial so probably
you're going to get a 50 degree
polynomial can be can can go up and down
so many times several times I think
technically a 50 degree polynomial you
can have
I think four
four Global four local
four local maximum all good minimum four
or five something like that so the
higher the degree is the more times you
can go up and down right so
um right because if you have a quadratic
the only thing you can do is this or
maybe this and for cubic you can do this
and for for first degree problem you can
probably do something like this right so
um so the exact details here don't
matter so uh just the the point is that
if you have high degree polynomials you
can it can be more flexible right and
then if you fill the data
um if you fetch the the polynomial to
the data then possibly you can organize
something kind of Plenty flexible
something like this
and actually if you really look up for
some like this is not required for this
course but if you look up the book
follow the calculus or like polynomials
you know that if you have four points
there's always a 50 degree problem when
they pass through all of them so in some
sense if you don't have enough points
and your degree is high enough then you
just you can always you can always make
the tuning out with zero literally zero
so in this case the tuning area is
literally zero
so
so and and then why right so I guess
this is expired and the the thing is
that so this is over 13 so but why
what's the problem here why is
overfitting so why
um the test is not good so in some sense
the kind of the
the intuition is that this kind of model
fits so it's faced to the Spurs patterns
to this
first patterns
um you know in the in a small and noise
data small
and noise data
so so this is because you don't have
enough data and your model tries to
explain all of this not small
perturbations small noise
and because it over expands the small
noise it lost it's it kind of like
didn't pay enough attention to the to
the more important stuff
and the reason why you can over refer to
the small noise the final data is
because
um because you you are you're so
flexible right so whatever patterns you
you see in these four points as long as
you just have four points whatever crazy
patterns you see you can always find the
degree five polynomial to expand it
right so so whatever patterns you see in
four data points you know like you can
explain it so that doesn't sound right
right so like how come your model can
explain like everything and anything
like a random so so basically you are
looking at the you are kind of like over
threading to the Spurs
um patterns um but instead of the the
big pattern so the big pattern is this
right the spur is fine inside of the
fluctuations in some sense
right so
um and so all the other words I think
you are you are explaining the noise
instead of the the ground truth
so
um and and okay how do you make this
intuition a little more formal so okay
I'm not gonna go very very formal but
like some more kind of like things I can
say about this intuition is that this is
saying that
you are sensitive
your model is sensitive or maybe kind of
like specific
to to the noise
how do I formulate this like one way to
kind of formulate this a little more
mathematically is that you can consider
you redraw
on the samples
and you ask right after you redraw the
samples are you going to see the same
model okay
right so you draw some new samples with
different Spurs packets right because
they are Spurs because they are noise
right so so if if you're if your model
is specific to the spirit's curtains
that means if you redraw you are going
to expect this you are going to learn
the new Spurs patches and you're gonna
have a different model and if you're not
specific or sensitive to Spurs patterns
even you have a new data set
you probably shouldn't change much but
you should still be somewhere to say you
should still out of the same model and
it turns out that if you have the five
degree polynomial you reach all the data
sets then you will find a new model so
what happens is I suppose you
um
read all the data set in the election
notes there are some real experiments
again but here I'm just gonna uh Jordan
so suppose for example now
you still have the same ground shoes
But You observe some
maybe let's say
here I'm going to have something upon
like this maybe developer like this
maybe yeah like hit this and
I'm going to try to make the pattern a
little bit different then maybe you're
gonna get
um something different Maybe
I don't know
like you try to find out what's the
polynomial maybe you want to guide
something like this
okay actually this these two are still a
little bit similar but I can't do
anything empirically you'll see that it
will be different just because you know
any small perturbations of this would
change a lot but maybe you you got this
so and and if you actually you can also
do some local thing right suppose you
move these points a little bit lower
then you probably would change this
function a lot so just because you are
very sensitive to the data phones
not increasing the number of samples
right so so far I'm saying that you you
don't you don't you don't you draw the
same number of samples with similar well
choose the same constitutional
institution but just the randomness are
different right you're using different
noise
so
um
right so and that's a good question
that's exactly what I'm going to talk
about next so so uh
um okay sorry one moment before that so
so basically okay just to summarize here
so if if you reach all the examples and
you find that a large variation between
so suppose you have a so you so you have
um
um so you call this so basically Define
the variance
to be uh in some sense the variations
across
um models
learned
on different data sets
so for example you draw five data sets
right so each data set has four examples
maybe and you try you do these
experiments and you get five models
learn now five different data sets so if
you see a lot of differences between
these models right so then that means
you have large variants
and and if you don't see a lot a lot of
differences then you don't have a large
virus that's the some of the formal
definition of this you know we will have
a little more formal version of this but
this is the idea
right so so maybe for example if you you
get a new data set you get
something like maybe here here
they're here and maybe you're going to
learn something very different maybe
something like this
right so and there are all some so here
at least you can see this one is very
different from this one because on the
left hand side here you're going up here
you're going down so
um so so that suggests that you have
large virus
and and now talking about data right so
suppose so so this one of the
characteristic of virus is that virus is
something that can be uh reduced if you
have more data
so
um and and in some sense the virus is
caused by lack of data and it can be
mitigated if you have more data
so let me continue here
keep all of these markers in my hand
otherwise I have to walk back and forth
Okay so
so the virus
and sometimes you can say this is caused
at least partially you know at least one
cause is that this is caused by lack of
data
and
um and okay of course you know it's
probably you cannot say this is only
caused by lots of data because you know
if you have
um a different model right it's a very
very so in some sense there are two
reasons one thing is it's like you have
lack of data and the other is you have
two expressive
too expensive models
and these two things are kind of like a
relative to each other right so if you
have
uh uh very expressive model but your
data is really really big then probably
is okay on the other hand you know if
you have not too many data but you have
very very simple model then it's
probably still okay so
um
and and as you can see that you know
then if these are the issue the reason
then you how to mitigate the virus then
the mitigation is just that
the medication is that either you get
more data
or you have small simpler model
so technically you don't have more data
if you have more data you should already
use them already but for the for the for
the
um for the understanding let's see for
example what happens if you have more
data with this what's this thing right
suppose you have more data
and you still fit a fifth degree
polynomial
so suppose you have a
a lot more data this is the ground shoes
and you
observe a lot of more data
as you have a million data right roughly
you know there's a little bit
fluctuation of course
so now you want to fit a 50 degree
polynomial what happens will be that
this is probably not entirely obvious
but like okay one obvious thing is that
you cannot you probably wouldn't do
anything like crazy as this right
because if you do this a crazy thing
maybe this crazy thing goes through some
parts but you cannot go through all the
points
right like for example right you can see
here is there's a big match between this
part and this point
right and here you have some
uh mismatch right so so this this one
wouldn't give you even a small training
error so this is not a best model
fit on the training data so what you
really will fit like if you minimize the
error on the training data with this so
many trillion examples then what you get
will get is probably something like this
more like this
maybe there's still some small fractions
it's not like necessarily matching
exactly the ground shoes but you have a
little bit smaller fluctuation but it
will be something like this because
because if you don't do this then you
wouldn't fix the original data as good
as well
and and this is you know
you know this is kind of like more like
a quadratic but you know but a fifth
degree polynomial contain the family of
degree 5 problem will contains the
family of quadratic function because you
can just thread you can just set your
Theta 5 say the four to be zero then you
get a quadratic so empirically what
you're going to do find is that probably
this if you really look at the details
this the best fit model is still degree
five polynomial but the set of five
Theta 4 the first few coefficients are
very very small so effectively you are
just very close to quadratic
oil
[Music]
s
right so so the question is like a um
another possibility is that affiliate
mode is that you just couldn't find this
degree five polynomial right you you
find because some optimization issue
right maybe even though there exists one
that is very good they face the data but
you couldn't find it
um that's that's that's probably not
true for the fifth polynomial for this
one entire example just because this is
very simple but it could be possible uh
for for some other cases where you just
the the model does exist but you cannot
find it so so this uh is something that
we don't discuss at least in the scope
of this lecture so in this lecture we
are we are assuming that you can just
optimization always works you always
find the best model so um so if existed
you can find it so
um so that's why like I'm I'm okay like
there's there in this case you know even
you have a lot of data right and even
have a very complex model say degree
five polynomial or even degree 10 maybe
in this case right so there's always
exists one model right that works which
is like something like this like like
the ground shoes and and and we'll find
it you know for this case definitely we
will find it because it's a it's a
linear regression problem you'll find
the best mode
right so okay cool so
um
and also another maybe just uh to to
answer the question so
um
um so in some sense the the problem you
are referring to is easier it's easier
to detect in some sense to some extent
it's not always true because at least
you can detect that from the training
right so here we are more talking about
the United States So Okay cool so any
other questions
is
yeah
yeah so so so so here when I say more
data I really mean that you have you
just collect you you have more data from
the same discussion like uh
from the same description
yeah yeah so like if if you collect more
data from yeah so like in sometimes you
you you you kind of like the
I'm not saying this is universally
applicable to every situation but the
main side we are in is that
um for example you have um
um how do I say okay you have a lot of
like a
um like medical images right so like
they are for example there is a million
patients with the cancer diagnosis kind
of thing and but not all of the data are
are labeled right so like only problems
at the beginning only for four four
images that are labeled as cancer or not
you know so and so forth and now but but
these four Images are sampled from this
big population and now I'm asking you
know I found out my variance is very big
so how do I mitigate that so I probably
one thing is that I can just sample more
data from the same
I started I have like one million
unlabeled examples right I I had four
labeled ones and now I'll say I'm going
to collect more labels so I sample like
another like 100 examples from the same
distribution and then I label them and
then I run algorithm when the variance
will be smaller
from troops
it is a leadership
so the question is that how do like if
you don't know the ground truth right so
how do you know that you are uh you're
having a large bias so so that's uh like
like a you you cannot really exactly
know when you don't look around truth so
all of these are so far are fall
analysis purpose right so when you don't
know the ground shoes
um you cannot really exactly like
um let me think so
um
yeah we don't know the ground shoes I I
think you cannot um exactly computer
bias
um because you know the definition of
device actually requires you to sample a
lot of uh like data right so you also
don't have infinite data so there's no
way you can evaluate the bias exactly so
so typically what you do is you say
um you fit the data on a training set
and you see you are under 13 and that's
that's when you say
innovating means like you have
um you have a large chaining error and
that's when you start to believe that
you have a large bias
this is a test error
yeah
I'll discuss that in a moment like
because I didn't I'm gonna draw this I
didn't even tell you what is I'll go
back to come back to this degrees
for highly imbalanced data set so maybe
let's discuss this offline I'm not sure
whether this I think it probably
requires more you know the investors
that is is pretty often you know like we
have research on that but maybe it's not
exactly related to the context here
maybe you can discuss offline
okay I think I still have something to
say about the virus
um and then I'll come back to the
trade-off
um
all right so so basically okay so now
let's see so let's Briefly summarize
um
so basically if you have the buyers
this is really just about the lack of
models expressively it's something of
intrinsic nothing to do with data right
this is just the uh lack of
if you have large bars that means you
have a lack of
um like expressivity
the model is not expressive enough
it doesn't depend doesn't depend much on
the data
um I guess you know
for linear models you can just say it
doesn't depend on number of data for not
only the models there is some
technicality you know which you know you
don't have to like the only reason why I
add much is just because you know
there's some technicality for that
provide me to say this is exactly
irrelevant to the number of data but but
you should basically just believe that
it doesn't it's it's intuitive it's not
a notion about how many data you have
it's really about how expressive your
model is
so um environments
you know if you have a large variance
then it could be two things but one is
lack of data
and another thing is you have a too
complex of a model
okay I guess I'm just repeating
summarizing and then I guess we can see
there's a trade-off
um so I guess I'll go to here so and
also there's a way to for you to prove
that test is equal to device plus plus
virus uh I don't think I have uh I will
see what I have time to discuss that
um but
um
but you can also prove the test error is
equal to by square plus variance
um so but maybe let's just uh
draw this from scratch so this side is
the model complexity right so let's
first think about how do you draw the
bias on the right this is the test this
is the um how do you draw the the bias
on this curve a smaller complexity
change so we say that the bias is large
it's because your model is not com mod
is not expressive enough so that means
that if your model is more expensive
than your battery decrease so that's why
the bias is a decreasing function as the
model complexity
right so this is the bias
and now let's let's think about how do
you draw the virus on this thing so we
said the variance is caused because you
have too complex of a model that means
if the model is more and more complex
then you should have bigger and bigger
virus that's why the virus is like this
and the test arrow is the sum of them so
so the test error is like a u curve
thing
so the test error wait
what is my oh here
so the test hour is the sum of these two
and
the environment
and and so the question you want to
answer is that if you change the model
complexity what is the best tester right
so so it means that somewhere in the
middle
so
um so so so like a um
actually there I'm going to tell you
something different from this you know
in a moment just though but it's
supposed to believe in this then what
the conclusion the implication of this
is that
um
you should um somehow kind of find a
sweet spot when you choose the model
complexity right so for example maybe at
the beginning you found that your
training error is very low so our
training value is very high which means
your battery is very very high right so
suppose your model complex is here
then suppose the model complex is very
small and then then what happens is the
bias is high and the bias is high it
means you are under 13 and means that
your training average is Big so
basically when you see the training
hours back you kind of see your biases
you kind of believe that your bias is
too high so that's why you should
increase the molar complexity and at
some point you found that you are you
know in the other regime where the virus
is too high then you should you should
stop so basically you increase the molar
complexity to some extent until you
violence
um uh is uh your bias environment has
the right trade-off
s
yeah so I think this this figure so this
is the okay you ask a good question
right so here this is the molar
complexity of the the model you use to
learn the the your your your parametress
model right so when you're asking about
what what happens if the ground shoes is
different right so
um the when the ground I think this is
now very sensitive to what the ground
truth is right there's always a
trade-off but but where the trade-off
comes from you know where The Sweet Spot
is would depend on the ground truth so
uh for example actually that's a very
good question for example suppose you uh
for for this data set right so probably
the best thing is to use quadratic
quadratic would uh has small enough bias
because you know quadratic is in
principle expressive enough to express
our data so that's why quadratic has
small bags and also quadratic is
probably the
among all the models with small bikes
among all the models that can express
your function quadratic is the least
complex right so that's why you use
quadratic that's the probably the best
solution
and if you really run random algorithm
the quadratic you would probably recover
something very close yeah so
um but if you're going to choose this
cubic then maybe the three spot is like
the the best trade-off is achieved at
Quebec Maybe
you know it's not they don't necessarily
have to match each other because it also
depends on the data uh how many datas
for example suppose you are maybe let's
let's give you an example supposed to
say
um your ground shoes is a degree 10
polynomial but they somewhat look like a
linear function so so suppose your
ground choose is a
ground shoes is like a
um almost linear but with a little bit
kind of like small fluctuation and but
you don't have a lot of data you just
have like a five data points right so
you just have five Training data points
and now if you want the virus to be
literally zero then of course you should
use
degree 10 polynomial because that's
that's the only case you are expressive
enough but maybe but then your virus is
too big so the so the right trade-off
here probably is closer to be a linear
because if you use a linear you bias is
not zero but still you know small enough
right uh and and in that case the
variance is small so
so so the right the best trade-off
depends on for example how many data you
have as well
right that's a good question and and the
answer to that is that no you cannot
come to the biotics and virus so all of
this um all of what we discussed today
is is more about
um some internal understanding so this
bias environment is not something you
can
um at least in some cases you can
estimate them a little bit but typically
you don't you probably shouldn't really
actively estimate the the bias
environments in your yours these are
mostly just for it's an internal
understanding for for for for our
research for ourselves but not
necessarily something you empirically
evaluate
um so okay so so I guess so one question
you know I guess many of you probably
are wondering you know if all of these
quantities cannot be even evaluated you
know how do you choose the right
trade-off what's the optimal model
complexity so what you do is actually
that's that's gonna be I think what we
discussed mostly next week uh next
lecture so
this is this is Wednesday right next
week yeah so um so you think the virus
or virus the virus and buyers are just
for understanding empirically what you
really do is that you try to you should
try to uh try a lot of different models
and you select based on a validation set
right but but this picture would let you
know
would help you a little bit in some
sense because for example suppose you
have tried this and this and this and
this suppose you have tried four model
complexity
right so and suppose you believe that
this is a u curve the test error is a u
curve then should you try even bigger
models be your family with models
probably you shouldn't right because you
believe that you kind of believe that it
will be even worse so so you should just
try even more in in the middle right so
that's the what's what this
understanding will help you
[Applause]
Okay so
um
there's some uh more formal definition
of the of the bias and virus and that's
in the lecture notes in section 8.1 I
think I don't have time to discuss the
formal uh definition even if the
definition I probably wouldn't be able
to give you the proof the proof is
actually relatively simple so if you are
interested you can you can read that
section yourself
um I don't think it's required for the
for the for the exam or anything
um but it's a relatively simple rate if
you're interested
and and also just this kind of bias
virus trade-off is not that always easy
to to achieve mathematically so uh for
square loss there is a classic you know
well established kind of decomposition
but if you don't have square laws you
don't have MSC like mean squared error
if you have cross entropy loss actually
it was open question how do you formally
decompose this so um so in all the
intuitions still apply right so but like
how do you do the mathematical
decomposition is actually pretty
challenging
um so that's why in the in the election
notes we only talk about Square loss and
any anywhere you if you read any
textbook or any literature probably they
were top top bars Square loss um but the
intuition is still kind of fine right so
if you don't care about what exact
definition of classes
so I will spend the next 20 minutes to
talk about
um
a new
um something that is actually
challenging this picture so something
that um so this is the maybe just follow
the more context so this kind of like a
u-curve test everyone best friends
trade-off this has been
um
um um like a this discovered or kind of
like analyzed for I don't know how many
years maybe like 40 years or something
like that but maybe like I I'm not a
historian so I don't know exactly which
is the the first time this is discovered
but this is like a very classic like a
like um however people realize that
there's some uh issues with this
understanding
um especially we realized that in deep
learning like you like actually people
start to realize this in deep learning
but actually it turns out that even this
understanding has an issue for linear
models
um so so this understanding has a it's
not complete uh it has uh it's Miss uh
it misses some uh some other things so
um so that's what I'm gonna talk about
um
and this is a this is the area of um uh
uh research productive in the last
probably three or four years so let me
try to
find out where should I erase
um
foreign
[Applause]
at the beginning and then analyze
theoretically this phenomenon is called
double design
if you are a historian then I think
actually this the the the this
phenomenal actually dates back to
something like 1990
um um some papers actually at that time
also pointed out this issue but I think
it just becomes popularized uh and and
more relevant these days and uh and what
does this mean is that so basically
I've told you that this is test error
this is model complexity I guess
technically here I'm writing a number of
parameters because
I want to be precise like imagine the
model complexity by how many parameters
you have
and the classical belief as we discussed
is that these test error should have
this u-curve
something like this
but then people realize that this is a
striking thing so people realize that if
you increase your model number of
parameters even more
at some point you will see that it will
be like this
so this is the basically this is the new
regime
that people cause this is the second
Descent of the test error
that's why it's called double designed
because there is a design here there's a
design here
and and this is the
um everything the blue part is what
people didn't realize
um as as much as as in the last four
years last four or five years and and
these are the so-called over
parametrized regime
foreign
so which means that in this regime
typically the number of parameters
is larger than the number of data points
in some sense this is the regime that if
you ask her you know
someone
20 years ago the news said this regime
is just a dead no-go Zone because you
should see very very bad test error but
it turns out that if you have more part
you make it even more extreme you make
the number of parameters bigger than the
number of data points uh you you may
actually
um is in not in all cases but in some
cases you may see uh the
um actually I wouldn't say I shouldn't
say more some cases like in many cases
like I could I'm not sure how to qualify
this but at least you know
a lot of cases
um you will see your second descent
so um so that's the Striking thing
the one with much more data
so is this
um
not directly let's say because this is
you know at least on the surface if you
look at this right so
you you your this regime is the regime
where the parameters is bigger than
number of data points
so so so if you want to find the right
course you know I'm not saying
um like you probably would say at least
you need to to be in this regime
probably you need to compute you need a
lot of compute because
probably you know like 10 years ago or
20 years ago you cannot even afford to
run experiments in this regime because
you don't you don't want to use that
many parameters because you don't have
enough compute right so but of course
you know in in nowadays we also have
more data points so and because we have
normal data points because we are using
Lightworks you know we we run larger and
larger experiments you know so so
indeed we it's correlates with more data
points like we do see more data points
in on these days right
so
um and this is the the so-called double
design phenomenon and it's kind of
mysterious
um uh it's a bit less mysterious these
days like after people have started
um this you know in the last five years
um very carefully
um I'll talk about some of the
explanations intuitions um but before
that let me also give another
um a related phenomenon which is
um also called double design but it's
called Model it's called Data wise
double desert so here I'm doing a
um a similar
I'm just showing a similar graph
but on the x-axis I'm going to change
the number of data points
so
so here the the y-axis is still a test
error
and the x-axis is
the number of data points
so and now okay maybe you have a guess
first you know what what this curve
should look like
well as you have more monitor points how
does the test error change
right the guess would be the test error
would be decreasing right because I
guess
here you know at least if you believe in
this biased environments kind of
intuition then the bias doesn't seems to
depend much on the data right the virus
will be smaller and smaller as you have
more and more data
right so
so then what you if you believe in that
then you should say that okay the test
error should look like this and it
should continue to decrease as you have
more and more data
and it turns out that actually
um in many cases what happens is that
the test error will look like this
I'll increase at some point and it will
decrease again
and on this peak here it's kind of like
similar to the peak here so this peak
it's often happening when
um
is roughly equal to D I guess by the way
here like you know there is a and this
is active research area so I'm not being
very precise in every places so
um so only is the number of examples
this is number of examples
this number of parameters
so what I said here um I think is
basically mostly a kind of 100 correct
for linear models but for non-linear
models you know whether this is exactly
n is equal to D or not it's a 2d or the
relationship is a little bit less clear
but let's say suppose we think about
relatively simple models and
um when the number of data points is
closer to the number of parameters then
in this case you you're going to see a
peak and then after that you have more
data it actually helps
I saw some questions
or does it eventually increase again
um so in the in the first year so in the
first figure this this is a good
question so I think I've seen
empirically
um
um both cases so sometimes it does
increase again a little bit but often
not much and sometimes I just keep
decreasing and sometimes it plateaus
so so I think that's why people probably
don't
study that part that much
yeah
this one I think is also new like I
think this actually the paper that first
systematically discussed this is like
2020.
um
this discovering the same paper right at
the peak there there is it's not
molotone the fact that
yeah I think at least uh you know they
might you know like immersion learnings
it happens so often that you know
someone did something and then people in
the community forgot about it
um that that's possible but at least I
would say like at least it's only until
2020 that people start to most people
start to realize this and because of the
that paper
uh I think the paper is just called
Model wise
because this is data wise because you
are changing the name of data points
right so
um okay so now okay this sounds like
mysterious enough right so like a very
very interesting
um and what's the what's the
explanations right in the last few years
um people try to explain why this what
happens right and I'll try to risk
ourselves with our old
um
understanding about this
um and also this is an important
question because this regime this blue
regime is actually
um actually you cannot you can it's a
it's not clear whether when you run like
a classical linear models I don't think
necessarily you're in this regime but at
least it's pretty clear that
um it's at least more it's more
um true that uh for for deep learning
you are basically always in this regime
at least it falls
I guess this is still you know it's not
it's never nothing is never universally
true but I think for most of evasion
experiments you are in this regime where
you have more parameters than a data
points so so this is something that is
really like a empirically relevant so
that's why people really care about it
so
um and maybe another thing I I need to
clarify is that I kept I think I I was I
think I probably mentioned that you know
this the study about the linear models
the phenomenon on linear models is um uh
is uh is more kind of clear like there
are a lot of studies and we have pretty
good conclusion and what I mean by that
is that even within linear models you
can try to change the model complexity
so what that what that means is that you
just insist that you always use linear
model but what you change is that you
you try to decide how many features you
use so you can start with only using one
feature or two features like for example
in the house price where you can use the
square foot as the single feature or you
can collect a batch of other features
right so keep adding more and more
features that means you have more and
more parameters right so so even within
linear models you can still change the
complexity just to clarify that
so I know and most of this theoretical
study I think are for linear models and
they are pretty precise these days
um and I'm trying I'm going to try to
kind of roughly summarize the intuition
from the study of this double design so
the intuition I think
um I'm gonna list a few
I've done so
foreign
so some intuition and explanations
and these explanations are mostly for
linear models
um
so I think the first thing to realize is
that this peak
so you can I can argue what is the most
exciting or surprising thing about this
graph right so but let's let's first
talk about the peak right this is a peak
in the middle
so I think the the first thing is that
in some sense people realize that the
existing algorithms
um especially if you just talk about for
example Simple Green descent or
sarcastic with instance for linear
models so the existing algorithms so
underperform
atically
um when n is close to the
so so it both these two peak are
basically like this right so here you
are changing n the number of data points
and you found that when n is close to D
you have to pick and here you are
changing the number of parameters you
are changing D the number of features
you use and we've realized when D is
kind of about n about the number of data
points you you have to pick so both of
these two picks two peaks are are
showing up here it's just that you are
changing the axis in something so this
is also
when
n is close to D
when the number of number of data points
is closed number of features
so so and and the the explanation is
such as the algorithms the existing
algorithms or the algorithms you are
visualizing here right so when you
visualize this right
you do you do ranks part some you do use
some algorithms to learn the parameters
so that particular algorithm that you
use to produce this graph is it really
underperforms very automatically it
doesn't it's not really saying that when
n is close to D the the real test I will
shoot with this it's just saying that
this algorithm is bad if you change your
algorithm you probably wouldn't see this
peak
so so that's why the peak shows up so
um and okay so so and what's what's
wrong with the the by existing algorithm
I really just mean that for example some
just basic reading decency so
um so for linear models maybe this is
let's say this is for linear models
so so what goes wrong with the so-called
existing algorithm right so this um
basically green descent algorithms so um
the the what goes wrong is that the norm
of
the the the the Theta
the the linear models you learned
uh
it's very big
uh when
is roughly equality
so and and I we kind of believe that
this is at least a partial reason for
why this leads to a peak so this gives
the peak
so even though um so okay so I guess let
me draw something here
we have some real experiment real data
in the lecture notes but if you draw
that Norm
foreign
so suppose you
you change the number of parameters
which means you add more and more
features in your you know in your data
set uh and so that you have more and
more parameters and you if you visualize
the norm
in the y-axis you're going to see
something like this
and this peak here
is roughly corresponds to and it's
closely
and which is kind of similar to these
Peaks
so so basically even though
suppose if you compare this this
experiment in this experiment right so
so here you have more parameters than
this than here
but when you have more parameters maybe
sometimes you have lower smaller Norm
so the norm is close to D for some
reason it's just very very big
and there they are actually we know the
reasons the reason is that some random
Matrix you know is not well behaved and
it's close to D but I guess we are not
going to go into that but at least the
immediate reason is that when n is close
to D somehow this algorithm is producing
a very large Norm uh uh classifier Theta
which is you know you can argue that in
the norm is if the norm is too big then
your model is too complex so so in some
sense this is saying that
if your model is actually very complex
so very complex
uh according to the norm
so this model
it simulator doesn't have a lot of
parameters compared to for example this
model so if you compare this model and
this model so this model seems to have
less parameter than this by definition
the norm is actually very big so in some
sense if you use the normalizer
complexity actually these Peaks have
large complexity
exactly
0.1
to give us
that's a great great question so so so
you got that you know I'm implying that
the norm seems to be a better metric for
the complexity right so what is the
right measure for complexity so this is
a very difficult question like for
different situations you have different
answers
um
um so so but you know there is no
Universal answer but Norm could be one
uh complex match in some sense the norm
is also a way to describe how many like
suppose you have a small normal right so
you have fewer choices to to fit your
data in some sense so you have a few
degree of Freedom if you have you know
in like you have a few options in some
sense to fill your data so that's
restrict the complexity and which Norm
that's that's actually
um for different situations you can
argue
which Norm is the right complexity
actually there's probably no Universal
answer but but well I guess what I'm
trying to say here is that the number of
parameters is also not necessarily the
right complex measure because if you
have more parameters suppose all the
parameters are very very close to zero
that's probably also a very simple model
because those parameters are not really
working right so so but if you have just
a few parameters but the norm is really
really big maybe you can use the the
right maybe it's used to also called
quality very complex so you know my
short answer is that there's no
Universal uh answer to this um um the
the point is that you know probably the
number of parameters is not the only
complex dimension
so and for linear model it just happens
that
for mathematical reasons I think L2
normally behaves really nice like it
seems to relate to a lot of like
fundamental properties like maybe you
can argue L2 Norm is useful because you
are measuring a square error in many
cases and it's it's nice with the linear
algebra so and so forth
okay so I guess let me I'm running a
little bit late but I think I'm almost
done here so
[Applause]
um right so so here it's just saying
that at least for this case it sounds
like Norm seems to be a slightly better
complex dimension
and and actually if you
um and you can test this hypothesis in
some sense so you can say that okay I'm
saying here the existing algorithm
underperforms but if you have a new
algorithm that's uh regularized suppose
you regularize the
um the norm I guess I haven't told you
exactly what regularization means but
here just what I mean is that you you
try to find a model such that the norm
is small
so so you add an additional term that
tries to make the norm small so you
don't only train on the tuning loss but
also you try to make the norm smaller
then you're going to see something like
this
so so regularization would mitigate this
to some extent I'll discuss more about
regularization in the next lecture but
here just it really just means that you
you don't you don't only care about
tuning loss but also you try to find uh
uh a model with small knobs so you and
you have some kind of like balance
between them right so you can sacrifice
a little bit of training hour but you
insist that you're normally small then
you can see this
right so so that in some sense explains
partially why you had a peak because the
peak is caused because your algorithm
was sub-optimal right your algorithm
didn't use the right complex measure and
you can fix that Peak by adding more but
there's one more question which is you
know there's no peak but why there's no
ascent
right so so suppose you just see this
right well actually here you also you
will also see this something like this
so this figure is actually pretty
reasonable because if your data point is
increasing you probably should just have
one decrease like you just keep
decreasing your
um or you you just keep decreasing the
the tester right so this one let's say
we are okay with that we're happy if you
see just a single
um single decrease
but here you're supposed to see a single
descent right I I feel like it's still
you know it's kind of arguable whether
you're you should be happy with this
answer because
um why when the number of primary is so
huge you can still generalize right so
why when you use for example a million
parameters and you just have like five
examples why you can still generalize
why you don't have a
Ascent eventually in many cases you
don't have a sign and in many cases the
best one is just you have more and more
parameters so
um and and actually for example another
question is that when number of
parameters is bigger than the number of
data points you know sometimes you are
thinking this is still you have too many
degree of freedom to fit all the
um specifics of the data set you
shouldn't generalize but actually in
particularly you do work pretty well
so that's the that's the last uh in
sometimes the another missing point a
missing part and this part
um we also have some explanation for
that and the explanation is that
so when any is very much much bigger
than d
[Applause]
sorry D is much better and the number of
parameters
is much bigger than
the the D that the uh sorry the much
bigger and the name of data points
so the thing is that
even though it sounds like you are
supposed to overfit but actually the
norm is small
but why the norm is small right why when
you have so many parameters you still
learn very simple model
the reason is that somehow there's a um
there is a there is a uh some implicit
regularization effect
which makes the norm small so so so when
you when we applaud this right so all of
these experiments didn't have any
regularization I didn't have any
explicit encouragement to make the norm
small so that's why the norm here is
very big but why the norm here is small
the reason is that your your
optimization algorithm has some implicit
encouragement to make the norm small
which which is not used which is not
explicitly written in the in the loss
function so
um and that's something I'm going to
discuss uh I think more next time
um
um right so so so for this lecture I
think I'm just so so we're going to
discuss this more uh next time so the
um yeah the high level thing is just
that something else is is driving the
norm to respond next